Marketing is an important step and
moving products from farm-to-table
farmers should consider marketing their
goods in more than one way and in more
than one location direct marketing
options include roadside stands that may
or may not be located on a farm pick
your own operations online platforms
community supported agriculture and
farmers markets stands should be on a
well-traveled road near a population
center they should have good visibility
from the highway be away from sharp
curves Hillcrest in high speed highways
have easy turn offs in return flow of
traffic provide plenty of parking space
offer access to power and clean restroom
facilities a farm may not be the best
location for sales a stand in another
location may be a better option stands
need a variety of produce but it can be
difficult for one person to grow
everything growers sometimes purchase
additional products from other farmers
pick your own operations are popular for
crops such as blueberries blackberries
strawberries and muscadines other crops
can also be marketed this way the
location of a pick-your-own farm is not
as critical as the location of a
roadside stand having customers doing
the harvesting requires less labor
handling shipping and storage at pick
your own farms think about parking
restroom facilities and additional
insurance needed because of a higher
risk of accidents online options are
available for marketing produce many
farms have websites electronic
newsletters text alerts Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages many farmers
post pictures of their harvested crop
and buyers contact them instantly
community supported agriculture is a
marketing option where customers pay
money before the crops are planted and
then receive produce during the season
farmers refer to this as purchasing a
share
and a customer could purchase half
shares or multiple shares depending on
the amount of produce needed these
shares are picked up at the farm or
another convenient location once a week
a farmers market has several advantages
the location is usually in a
high-traffic area it provides small
farms with a sales outlet it is a great
way to advertise farm products that
rapping at other times of the year the
disadvantages of a farmers market
include time and travel away from the
farm and consumers who purchase in small
quantities before participating at a
farmers market
contact the market manager request
information on rules for a particular
market times location today's open fee
and albums allowed to be sold